I'm here to talk about logging
infrastructure at Pinterest and I'm
speaking with you yang who's actually
built most of this and we're also going
to follow up with some of the things
that we have done to manage log quality
so this is the agenda so just a brief
overview of what Pinterest is and and
like a deep dive into a logging
infrastructure and then some things that
we have done to manage log quality
software aspects of how do we make sure
that the data that we are collecting is
actually of high quality and then we can
get into the questions part so start
with what is Pinterest right I don't
know how many of you use Pinterest what
we think of Pinterest is is is what we
call is a discovery engine so it helps
you find interesting things and so when
we say that people will ask like how is
this different from Google so this is
like hey I mean if you have a question
if a fact-based question like what's the
weather in SF today and you can type in
keywords and Google and gives you a
really nice answer and that solves your
sort of question another fact waist
question or the central limit theorem
again Google does a great job
it basically retrieves they actually
answer for you to actually like go off
and read it not bad right I mean this
this is really interesting stuff and
Google has built an amazing search
engine over the years to actually solve
these kind of problems but if you have
this kind of question what should I cook
for dinner today I mean if you enter you
can enter these keywords in Google I
don't think Google is gonna answer your
questions right this all depends upon
your personal tastes and what you like
and sort of this is something that
Google is not aware of similarly if
you're interested to discover your own
style like what what kind of clothing or
accessories should I buy or I'm actually
what what am i resonating with or where
should I go this summer right so these
are questions that are very personal to
everyone and there's no one definite
answer and this is where I think
traditional search engines like Google
and Bing fail and this is the discovery
problem that Pinterest is trying to
solve
and how do we solve this we start with
this one
object this is a pin this is a
representation digit digital
representation of a real-world objects
in this case is a watch and the pin
comes with like a picture and some
description a title and it is associated
with the collection of other pins so in
this case this pin belongs to a
collection of watches this is the
collection of watches that I am pinning
on Pinterest which means that I am
actually collecting a Petaling Pinterest
this this is this is my taste around
watches right and and then most all of
our users I mean we have millions of
users doing the same thing in creating
these pins curating these pins and into
various collections we take all of this
data and apply algorithms to create a
set of recommendations for our users to
actually go and discover new things it's
not new I mean companies like this done
have done this before Amazon if you've
gone to Amazon you it actually shows you
recommendations of what you have bought
before so we apply the same kind of
algorithms obviously like we have a lot
more interesting data we have a lot of
image data to process as well also and
then we create this feed this is a feed
of recommendations that our users go and
see when they come to Pinterest and and
we are constantly trying to improve the
relevance of this feed to make sure that
we are actually serving the right
quality of recommendations and behind
all of this is data right I mean we're
we have collecting huge amounts of data
both the actual data around pins but
also a lot of activity data we rely on
like user feedback what I use is
repenting what I use is clicking what I
user searching for on the side all right
so we collect all of this data and then
make it available for processing and
power both in sites like to run our
experiments to make our decisions but
also more importantly for our products
like recommendations search things like
that
so at a high level this is how our data
architecture looks like we have
thousands of web servers basically
our clients talk to for both sort of
like logging activity data and also for
just general sort of keep retrieving
recommendations and and then that we
have run this custom logging agent
called singer which you yang is going to
talk about on all these servers which
basically collects all of this data and
writes - Kafka so we've we've been
working with Kafka for a couple of years
we have tuned a lot to make it run scale
ibly in the cloud so we're gonna share
some of our experiences doing that and
once Kafka once the data goes into Kafka
then it has like kind of this lambda
architecture way of - we crossing the
batch pipeline basically copies the data
from Kafka into s3 so we use s3 as our
data warehouse which is this is
basically where we keep all of our data
and from there on we use cueball which
is like a Hadoop as a service provider
to run our like basically process our
data so if they provide us with Hadoop
and spark clusters so we then run our
ETL jobs to manage all of this data we
build some custom sort of tools to
manage all these ETL workflows we've
open sourced this workflow management
system called pinball last year and then
and all of this data then goes into the
different things so essentially some of
this data is going into the product like
directly as recommendations and then it
is going into our analytics system
called panel ethics that helps us to
look at business metrics every day it
helps it helps this data is also
powering or a be testing dashboards and
then it also goes into redshift has an
an aggregated form for our analysts to
query and we also have the real time
pipeline right now we are using storm
we're actively investigating a stream
processing engine that replaced I'm
personally I actually let the storm
project a Twitter so I know both in a
sort of the pros and cons of it and
there's a talk today Karthik is going to
talk about the Twitter here on which is
this zombie - so if anyone is interested
okay so and then we have the real-time
pipeline then basically takes the data
from storm and we've had this custom
event processing engine called stingray
which we use for a lot of like sort of
filtering
and sort of action bay action taking and
sort of processing rules on top of event
data mainly for spam detection and other
things like sending emails and
notifications this is not open sourced
yet we might we might be doing that
sometime this year and then that
actually also serves the data into the
product so that's kind of a high-level
overview of the data architecture with
that we'll go into the logging
infrastructure and I'll hand over the
mic to you yang to go over it so hello
everyone so so I'm going to continue
talking about the logging infrastructure
we built at Pinterest we do want to
share our experience here and collect
feedback from the community and also
improve our logging infrastructure oh
cool
so first let's talk about requirements
for the log infrastructure what do we
what are logging infrastructure required
so and there are a few high-level
requirements about the log
infrastructure first is the availability
the infrastructure should be always up
and running right and no downtime
allowed second is about the minimized
data loss zero data loss of course this
distributed system is not perfect there
can be incidents et cetera but we want
to have minimal data loss through the
pipeline the third part is the
horizontal scalability so the
trafficking goes up and down so to
minimize the efficiency will always want
to maximize the efficiency right we want
to have the best utilization with our
computation resources and nostalgy
resources meanwhile so how can we do the
horizontal scalability when the traffic
ramps up right and the traffic the
system should continue works when the
traffic goes up ten times if a third
that the fourth bullet is low latency
the event should reach there and should
we conserve ailable for consumption
within seconds right our fleet being
logged reached our server point server
side the last part is I think is also
very important for us is their operation
overhead right the system should be up
and running with minimum human
intervention
and so streamlines are this is
especially important for us which has
only limited limited amount of staff for
running the system so let's dive deep
into our logging infrastructure first
let's look at a very high level overview
of our infrastructure so our logging
infrastructure is a very highly waste
very thing for a it's just collecting
the logs and putting the logs into
storage for later consumption and it has
primarily three blocks wines their app
server where the services are running
and we're collecting the all the events
of the messages we collect from the
client apps the third part the second
part is a message transportation here we
use the over install system for kafka
that is a very nice horizontal scalable
reliable system to do the message of
transportation the third party is also
the data transportation out of the
message queue like half car right
because we have a huge amount of data
coming in every day and their message
akyüz can only cache the messages for a
limited amount of time we need to
transfer that out of the message queue
and starting there's cloud storage how
can we do that reliably and efficiently
that's also a challenge for us currently
as also we describes there a brief
flight
Pinterest logging scale currently we
have tens of thousands of hosts run in
the cloud we are only running in the 80s
right now and we are logging more than
120 billion messages per day and we use
their kafka as our central message
transport rotation hub and currently we
have the cluster size about more than
500 brokers and we have there developed
some in-house technology for logging
messages transporting messages from our
app servers to half-car and also
transporting data from Kafka twist 3
which is our source of choose for their
downstream processing so first let's
retrospect saw the evolution of our log
infrastructure
so this diagram shows the v1 version of
our login infrastructure where we were
using this is about two years ago when
we using a 4.7 and when Kafka doesn't
provides replication for the messages
and this inference track is quite a
simple when a message reaches our server
side and the server just directly writes
a message - al-kahf car and it's on
Kafka we have a demon we call the data
uploader just running there and
periodically upload the data into s3 and
from there also we have the of course to
the real-time consumption services from
Kafka and from the s3 part and we have
the batch processing kicking to do there
for the data processing so and this
diagram is very simple and because of
there is no data replication and we just
needs the dead uploader running on each
of the broker to upload their Kafka
messages al-kahf called files to s3 from
there we can have their converting job
to convert the Kafka logs in to order
down streaming data that the further
processing is needed so there are a few
problems with this Piatt this kind of
the pipeline the primary problem is the
dead loss the Kafka brokers can go down
unexpectedly if the broker fails and
basically there is because there is no
replication all the data on the broker
will be lost if the data has not been
uploaded to s3 the second is because we
have the application servers writes
directly to Kafka if there is high back
pressure and behold we do the directory
writing we need to cue the messages in a
memory buffer before writing to Kafka so
if there is a spike of traffic and there
is high pressure back pressure in the
message queue and the message we can
overflow there will also be data loss
and the second part is about operability
because of the kafka brokers can go down
at any time and also because of the
limitations and in the implementation of
the cough car consumer etcetera and each
time that his brokers goes down and when
you can replace the broker and then we
need to also restart or do is rolling
wrists are of the earning dependent at
all streaming services to make sure that
they pick up their right broker list and
that's add a lot of operating overhead
so because of this and we switched user
the later versions of Kafka that's the
post replication and starting with a
half a point a right but with challenges
with with cow the calf cattle suppose of
replication there are also a few
challenges first is because of the
introduced of replication now a message
can have multiple copies lives in
different brokers and with this the our
original approach of using data loader
to upload the data to the calf car to s3
itself will not work because you don't
know which broker has is a leader is a
leader for the tropic conditions and the
topic partition leaders can change
frequently a second part and we can no
longer randomly pick up a broken right
to and when we write try to write to
Kafka and we need to know their leader
of the topic partitions and we also need
to handle all the corner cases of the
when when the Kafka broker is
unavailable or when a few topic
conditions become unavailable or in the
middle of the leader election so and
there is the next slide I will show user
and so here is their our login
infrastructures v2 in which we evolved
we add a few
building blocks which shows in the blue
blue box here first on our app server we
changes the mode of directory writing to
the cough-cough car brokers we have our
services write messages to local log
files from there we have developed
in house logging agent record singer
that reduce lock messages and upload
logs to a Kafka the second piece that we
developed is there data transportation
service that we developed two versions
first version we called sacred and
second version we Cartman said to move
data in volume from Kafka to s3 and and
the third block that we added is the
data sanitization because and the the
first part of the singer and Kafka and
the second part the whole pipeline
suppose at least once message delivery
right there could be duplication if
there could be duplicated messages
introduced along the pipeline and also
there could be data corruption
introduced because of the incredible or
because of there some users just there
intentionally write some bad messages
into some pipelines et cetera so as a
final stage we introduce that data sign
and sanitization which is sanitize the
data and before the doing therefore the
processing so this is a very high-level
overview of our logging infrastructure
and the latency right now from there
from the event which our endpoint to log
to Kafka is being within within seconds
usually under five seconds and the forms
are moving data out of Kafka as three
part we can do either hourly ingestion
or their daily insert stream so it
depends on the requirements of our
customers so at the same time we also
uses with half a point eight we are also
using storm and sparks we also explore
exploring spark streaming to do the
real-time data processing further our
data pattern yeah so in the next few
slides I will dive deep into the singer
and the second part and I we also we
also talked about our experience of
running Kafka in reliable innings or AWS
public cloud and first let's talk about
the logging agent part right a singer so
our logging agent the logging is at very
high level it's very simple right it's
just right
messages to to a lock repository like
the cough Cara it's very simple but
there are also a few challenges that we
face the first is the reliability right
the logging agent should be very
reliable always up and running and
they're keeping uploading logs to to
their message queues the second part is
about high throughput and low latency
the logging agent should be high
efficient and can low can upload a huge
volume large volume large volume of data
and with a minimum amount of the latency
to the message report no message queues
and also is we need to be highly
efficient to minimize their CPU
footprint and also the memory footprint
in the house and another requirements
are coming from there our customer is
it's needs to support various a log
format because we not only love logs
from our the service that develops at
Pinterest but we also needs to upload
the logs from various third-party
softwares
also for all the open source of the logs
from open source software's so we need
to handle various format and to do the
and support plugins to do the message
filtering another part that's important
is we need to him to make sure there is
a fair scheduling so that the logging
agent needs to upload the logs in in low
latency not only for those logs
pipelines in large volume but also for
those low volume topics right how do we
guarantee the fare schedule fair
scheduling is also important part so
let's look at the logging agent of a
singer the singer is a just logging
agent with developed at Pinterest and
it's the high-level concept is very
simple and it's just as the application
servers and using some client library to
write logs in either thrift format or
text format and to the local file from
there and the singer picks up and the
rights and write those messages to
Kafka or the other message queue systems
so the reason we choose this
architecture is the primary reason is
try to tea cup holder the various
systems so we want to isolate the
logging agent failure from the
application failure application server
so minimize if the logging agent fails
right it will not cost a loss there the
application server just rise logs to
local disk and the logging agent can
steal pick up later and upload logs to
the message queue the second part is
about we want to D cup holder a minimize
impact of this message message queue
failures so if the Kafka is down and the
logs can be still cached on app servers
and can be uploaded later so with the
thin singer is implemented in Java and
we and it's a high performance a logging
agent we can achieve more than 100
megabytes per second uploading to Kafka
for those for the thrift log messages
that we have at Pinterest and it
provides a few production support
environment support features including
the dynamic configuration detection and
because there the production teams can
continuously adding or removing
configurations adding new pipelines or
remove the existing pipelines from there
from the environment how to handle this
and cases and minimize operation
overhead is the important part for the
logging agent the second part is to the
second feature is adjustable logging
latency for some log streams
we may need very low latency for some
other while at the same time for some
other log streams it may the customer
may define with their saying 30 minutes
latency so we have there all the not all
the prep configuring configurable can
parameters that allow singer to tune the
various size like the logging latency by
uploading et cetera to and to fit into
the various performance
the third part the second the third
feature is the auditing right because
and we need to gain confidence about
their about login so if the logging
agent how do we know the logging agent
is uploading order the full set of data
right and if some messages is missing in
the middle of the pipeline and we should
be able to detect and response faster so
we need to end it and we need an entry
and auditing feature and the single
supports auditing feature so that allow
us to the end to end message auditing
the last part is their heartbeat
mechanism because singing is wrong a
singer is running as their a standalone
process on each of the hosts if the
singer is down and then and we and if we
cannot detect this in time then the lock
will be the logging will be delayed or
we may face potential death loss right
how can we make sure we can aware of the
singer a logging agent failure and alert
has get alerts on time when the logging
agent fails our hosts the heartbeat
mechanism helps to prevent this so with
a heartbeat the single rise heartbeat
message to a specific kava kava queue
from where we can do the aggregation and
monitoring and compare with the hosts
that the little house that already been
launched and alert us on time when some
failure happens and next I will talk
about the brief talk about the internal
of the singer and singer is implemented
using a stay at a stage to even a driven
architecture in which we have they're
divided divided logging processing into
multiple stages including the
configuration file detection and the log
log files change events monitoring and
the log file reading and log file
writing and the finals are one piece is
miss is omitted in the block is is a
network transportation to cover so in a
very high level we just
a few building blocks we have a lock
monitoring thread that a continuous
monitoring through our configuration
directory and the true to pick up the
new configurations and we also have our
file system monitor that continuously
listening to the multiple lock
directories and receive the and started
sending and there start sending events
to the later processing layer try to
notify that there are new logs to be
processed on new lock streams to be
picked up and in the long process apart
we have their multiple threads pools to
do the parallel processing we have a set
of readers try to read the messages from
those lock streams and we also have the
right set of writers to a hook up of
each of the readers and two of the lock
stream to write a lot of messages to
Kafka so under the underneath and we
have another thread prune that a network
transportation layer that to parallel
paralyze the writing to Kafka so we
break down each batch into multiple
small packages based on their signature
to each topic partitions so that we can
do the parallel writing to each of the
topic partition to speed up the
throughput so that's a single part the
next part we will talk about about our
experience of running and Kafka in the
cloud so kapha is a awesome open source
software but and it's very reliable when
we're running on premise hardware but
when we running in the cloud there are a
few new challenges we faced one is the
brokers can get down unexpectedly
because of various reasons there could
be a small scale a doubles a SS outage
or maybe a physical host in a debate
sits down and you happen just how to
have multiple virtual instances running
on that host and so many reasons that
progress can go down unexpectedly the
second part is so the EBS IO performance
can degrade a significant array and due
to the resource contention so if you
know more about the EBS
internal so there there are the EBS has
our data volumes how they're the EBS
volumes host under physical host and
because we don't have control on the EBS
volume allocation multiple EBS volumes
that used by our Kafka services make it
allocated on the same physical host and
when the load goes up it ends up a
multiple EBS volumes can have the
contentions got contentions and the
performance of the i/o throughput got
significantly significantly degrade and
it causes the latency in our tailpipe
line and also um because of the and also
we are using we were using the small
instances like C 3 X C 3 to X or D 2 X
large for our Kafka brokers while with
this cough Amazon can Co log co-locate
multiple virtual instances in the same
physical host so then if you have the
physical host failure at Amazon data
center it may affect multiple virtual
machine instances in our cluster right
and in the replication with the kafir'
interpretation if you have three
replicas while you have all the three
replicas on this running on the same
physical host and if that physical host
fails basically you lose all the data
for that a partition that would be very
bad and the third the last part is about
the faster recovery so when the when
something bad happens in the cloud right
how can we fat recover the service
faster and bring it back to the normal
stage that's something that is also a
challenging for us so the next slides we
are talking talk about our experience of
this so our initial setting with Kafka
is that we use a c3 2x large plus EBS as
our settings because the c3 instances
doesn't provide in enough local storage
and so we use the EBS to as the
supplemental storage but this gives a
problem the primary problem that this
gives us is there EBS IO performance
degradation because of the content
that we have among the EBS volumes so
starting from the earlier last year when
the t2 instance is released which is the
new Kafka the new ADA based instance
that spawns local disks we switch the d2
which allows the using we use the local
disks to avoid the EBS contentions and
algae also we use that there are
multiple of kind instance types in the
d2 family
it's a d2 x large t2 2 x large and the
four x large and 8 x large right and a
various size we choose a smallest
instance type to make sure that - to
minimize the data footprint on each of
the broker so that one broker fails we
can quickly transfer all the data to
another broker and get recover faster to
address the topic partition physical the
colocation failure colocation problem so
we needed to make available zone aware
perishing allocation so that we so
currently our policy is for each topic
condition needs to be stayed on the
three different of available zones if we
find some topic partition is not a valid
only on one or two available zones we
need to then have some scripts to move
it a way to move it to some new brokers
to make sure we have the available
available zone of a where replication to
make sure to avoid is the minimize
impact of their physical host failure
the last part and our experience is it's
better to have multiple small clusters
then adjust a gigantic cluster so we
deployed multiple small clusters which
is only have 20 to 40 brokers per
cluster to provide the topic level
isolation so make sure if one cluster
has problem it doesn't affect their the
topics on other clusters so this is a
briefly summary of our experience
experience with Kafka alright and the
next part we will talk about our data
persisting power
right which I will talk about the
challenges we have in our experience of
transporting data from Kafka to s3 or
the other cloud storage so for the data
transportation part so there are a few
requirements that we need to we want to
achieve the first is a strong
consistency we won't have each message
to be persisted into the cloud storage
exact ones and we don't want to persist
in multiple times right for efficiency
reasons and also we definitely need for
the tolerant and in the data transport
is in service if any of the broker any
of the worker knows Goes Down and we
this should be transparent to us and and
the work the work should be be able to
be picked up by other workers and to
continue and we also need to have the
even load balancing to make sure we can
handle the traffic spikes a fine and of
course the horizontal scalability is
what the basic requirements the last
part and we we also need to configure
configurable makes the system very
flexible forbearances configure various
configurations like the upload a policy
and final destination and also data
retention policy et cetera
so based on these requirements and we
developed it of initially our solution
is Sakura witches uses the high level
consumer to read messages from Kafka and
and relies on the internal mechanism of
high level consumer to distribute if
there is a work across multiple workers
all right
so second has a nice feature and it has
it we use the zookeeper to keep track of
the progress of each worker of each
topic relation and so we have a
mechanism to guarantee is a strong
consistency so for each message who can
be possessed the exact ones and also and
the the Kafka high level consumer
provides a nice feature of the photo
tolerant if any worker knows is down
and Kafka a client library will be able
to detect the failures fail the nose in
the consumer group and pick up right by
having to pick up by some other host
single group and it has a load work
distribution and also we have the
configurable after the policies research
all right implemented the exact row
but with sacral with the Kafka that uses
high-level consumers and we have the few
challenges that when we try to operate
the these data fence partitioning
service in at a scale in the cloud so
these are the challenges that we faced
the so Secor uses cover high-level
consumer and we should use it which is
actually is the consensus based workload
the distribution implementation the
multiple consumers in the group needs to
talk to each other and make a consensus
are the were clouded workload the
distribution if there is any failure
that is detected by some of the broker
or some of the consumers and there is a
low workload rebalancing will be
triggered and if the rebalancing is not
successful and and there will be another
iteration of is rebalancing until
another consensus is reached right by
the consumers in a group so but in our
experience and this kind of consensus
based workload the distribution can
cause trouble in in various scenarios
when there especially when the dead
volume is high when if if the data
volume is high and also there is a
workload
consumer group rebalancing and it can
consist lags in there in processing that
head to the final cloud storage and
because we don't have control of the
consensus election right and there is no
way we can if there is lag there is no
easy way for us to mitigate the problem
and catch up and this is really bad for
us
and also because of this we try to
minimize the impact of their the
consumer groups rebalancing in Kafka by
isolated topics into different consumer
groups but then this as much more less
more old over headed to us under
distributing the workload among multiple
topics and it's very inconvenient for us
to add new topics and add a new or
dynamic add topics or remove their
topics from the data pipelines and also
the for the efficiency part the high
level consumer has a crime library look
after high level consumer client library
has an increment has a few nice features
like the group program rebalancing
workload rebalancing and failure
detection et cetera but this also adds
overhead answers saying consuming
messages from cough Karen so given this
and we improve our data transportation
service and evolve into a second version
we chordoma said there must in the Masad
we try to remove the workload at
distributing workload distribution
decisions that is made by the cough
client library so in my said we just
directly using the Khafre single
consumer try to have each worker to use
cough a single consumer to consume data
from Kafka and we you we employed a
master worker approach in which the
master reads the configuration files and
create his work assignments meanwhile
the workers read the assignment work
assignments and whose actual work from
reading data from Kafka and persisted to
s3 the master to the other work of
saying the dynamic configuration
detection order and uploading policy
change or the data retention policy
change et cetera now why is the worker
just do the single work of the reading
data from Kafka and upload it to that's
three so and mask and worker to
minimizing to decaf cause the dependency
between the master and workers we use a
zookeeper to as a broker for their data
communication the master just write all
the assignment
information to zookeeper and the worker
can pick up and also the workers right
all this probe the progress the status
report
there are status report itself to
zookeeper so that mask and now the
worker status so we have deployed there
we have the Mossad a service has been in
production for months and is
transporting almost all its all of our
data from the calf car to s3 and and we
also build some nice UI to allow us to
immediately see the progress of each
topic partitions to make sure so and if
something if something bad happens we'll
get a load here - based on the various
metrics we are monitoring so that's all
the building blocks we have built of
English infrastructure part next I will
hand back to Krishna he will talk about
the block quality thanks you so one of
the things that we wanted to make sure
is because we is relies so much on data
at the end of the day we are kind of
building a data product we need to be
really really sort of careful about and
ensuring that the data that we are
collecting a sort of high quality so we
made some investments to actually both
tools and processes and culture wise to
actually make sure that the log quality
is actually high a high level we look at
log quality as two things right
one is reliability completeness aspect
are we collecting all of the data and so
there's a lot of the logging
infrastructure that we have built up is
geared towards that so essentially no
data loss and availability of data in
reasonable amount of time and and and
then the other aspect is the correctness
of data essentially this is where is
like require some human interpretation
and there's a lot of things that can go
on developers who actually ship features
may actually forget logging data or may
break existing logs or in some cases
like our ETL jobs that process the data
could actually be doing something
incorrect so a lot of these changes are
hard to find so some of the challenges
is like if you are a feature developer
on iOS or Android
engineer instrumentation is like an
afterthought you don't really think
about it while you're actually building
the feature right just before you
actually try to launch it you've you
kind of sort of think about it the other
thing is features can be shipped
breaking sort of logging or without even
adding new logging so and if an if a
release goes out to the wild I mean iOS
or Android and it just takes weeks for
the data to be corrected because like
four weeks for it to be actually
upgraded so even if you release the dot
released it'll takes a lot of time for
it to actually catch up
and unlike code quality bugs data
quality bugs are hard to find so a
developer can actually may introduce a
subtle bug in logging that sort of
changes our DEA use and some time like
maybe a month or a couple months later
an analyst actually looking at it and
say something like finds a discrepancy
and it just makes it really hard to
actually go and fix it and and patch it
so in order to do that we started with
first thing is introduce like tooling
right like as engineers we wanted to
make sure that can we actually
automatically detect things and so one
of the things that we built out was this
tool called Firefly which essentially is
a few a few components to it at a very
basic level the first version was just
hook up to Kafka and and inspect logs
like real time crap right like basically
like introduced some keywords and
inspect the logs and and and then we
later on worked on the reversion to of
it which is to act had this sort of what
we call real-time checkers so these are
the invariants that we actually make
sure that they're always respected so
you can call them as data unit tests in
some ways so we then say like okay we
before every release we we try to make
sure that we play with the app and and
and and and run Firefly on all the
events that that came out of the of that
sort of pre-production build and ensure
that the logging changes there were no
regression Logging's and things like
that and then we also built up our
anomaly detection tooling to ensure that
hey like are the metrics that we are
computing are there anomalies in it so
this will also help us to catch things
that if there are bugs in the ETL
pipeline or sort of data ingest
so the way we done it essentially is
very simple so we take a look at like
the last few weeks worth of data and
assume the data is normally distributed
and then we look take a look at the
today's data and see like what's the
p-value so how much statistically it is
deviant from the from the previous data
and so if the p-value is less than some
threshold we when we look at all those
metrics that actually have that the the
p-value less and that sholde and mark
them as anomalies and so this actually
helps us to find periodically so every
day this email goes out a bunch of
people in the company that care about
data and they look at it and we actually
segment it to like hey like team based
or individual based and so essentially
so that they can actually look at in
this case this is actually showing or
weekly a per active rep inner symmetric
case has some anomalies in it and actual
values are hidden for obvious reasons
but but you can actually see how the
format looks like so so how did we do so
this this kind of anomaly detection
actually helps us find various things
here actually there are two things like
expected changes and unexpected changes
so someone is running an experiment in
an anomaly that they find is actually
expected and obviously things that we
don't expect we should be able to find
there and also you sort of user facing
and non user facing so things like when
we introduced this feature called
users can follow interest in addition to
other users and Pinterest then we
actually saw this sort of interest
follows when top and and and things that
we don't expect to see like when
tracking changes that that basically get
detected because of some unexpected
logging changes however one thing that
we found is no matter how much tooling
and automation that we do there needs to
be a manual step towards ensuring
logging data so we do have will be
basically introduced this culture and
process around auditing logs just before
application release go out so manual
audits are not scalable they have their
own limitations but they do catch very
critical bugs so we have introduces a
repeatable process of like two things
one is a regression audit ensuring that
we basically make the core logging
actions we do we do a cold
actions and and and so like using the
tool to verify the output of those
actions and then new feature audit so
and this is a little this is sort of a
little difficult in the sense that when
featuring you're creating in your
feature they need to think about
instrumentation they need to sort of sit
with the business analyst or or a data
engineer to ensure that like hey are the
events that I am producing are actually
the right kind of events that will help
you measure my feature and then sort of
and then logging them and actually
verifying if the logging was done
correctly so so some of those things
actually helped us so it's like a bunch
of tolling and some process and that
sort of help us on a day-to-day basis so
in terms of somebody won some of the
things that we found were investing in
our logging infrastructure has really
helped us right so I think we've
invested in pretty early on they were
focused on things around like minimizing
data loss and completeness of data we've
invested on Kafka we had options being
on AWS to use some of the AWS services
but we picked Kafka and it actually sort
of helped us Kafka's matured a lot and
all the investments in time that we put
into qunit to get it working on the
cloud is actually paying off and data
quality is not free I mean that's
something that we have learned hard
wavey when I joined Pinterest we had
releases going out with no user ID
logging for some features so we had no
insight into how those features were
actually doing so it's not free so one
needs to pay attention to it on on a
regular basis and automation tools get
you a long way
pre-release and post release automation
tools to detect logging bugs and the
hard part is data quality is actually a
really difficult problem compared to
code code and that's one thing that I
have kind of learned in the last two
years and then the other part is just
culture building so I think it's it's
just not one team that's responsible for
this thing we need to put everyone sort
of the the mobile engineers and sort of
the product managers and the business
analysts we should it should be like a
common sort of effort to ensure that
data that we are collecting is a
high-quality and that's something that
we've tried to do at Pinterest so that's
kind of the end of it so yeah if you
have any questions whether
you're hiring so if you're interested
you can reach out to me or you yang and
if you have any questions I'm happy to
answer you as well all right this
question is for mr. yang basically you
mentioned in the singer the heart thing
and errors relation can you a little bit
deep dive in that heart beat and the
singer oh so so the question is about
the heart beat in the singer in Canada
right so and the heart beat message is
so we implement the featuring singer
that periodically just it's a
configurable parameter that we can every
specific interval saying 10 seconds or 1
minute whatever you send a message to a
specific kafka topic from there so you
have a we have a downstream consumer and
just continuous reading from that topic
and aggregate all the information and
check we have also have a separate list
of a host that's running so that's
updated every 5 minutes something that
we can compare this to lists to see what
Hardware the process is not running so
then we have the some automated recovery
through there another monitoring system
for instant Naturals whatever
it's wondering if you could talk a
little bit more about the sanitation
piece that you mentioned I didn't
exactly understand if if you were
enforcing the strong consistency via
that piece or that if that was part of
Merced and then also if you're doing the
sanitation in that way how you ensure
that your batch analyses are actually
only operating on the sanitized data
good question so the sanitization part
so and let's first let's respect is
there a singer Kafka second type line
right the singer itself and only
guarantees at least once delivery
because if the singer try to load a
batch - Kafka and it fails in the middle
of the uploading right and it may retry
again but in the rich wild part and part
of the part of the patching the pre may
have been success in previous attempt
right so this part introduced is where's
most Rivoli most of the duplication is
introduced the master part is guarantees
exact one-time delivery is from the read
message from Kafka for each message you
read out of Kafka we can guarantee you
just put it once into l3 but for the
original parts and it's not so and the
sanitization part we've run this as a
Hadoop job under our Hadoop patch
processing part so we have a workflow
that Greta's our raw data and sanitize
it and putting the new location for the
downstream process downstream in
processing so yeah so I'm interested in
the audit logging process of singer how
do you edit those and how do you upload
those those go with Kafka as well yeah
great question so the auditing part is
we implement this this way so for singer
internally it's to the bash uploading
for each batch of messages is rise to
Kafka and we also we create a another
audit message right to a separate topic
saying oh the audit topic now this is
for this
and this host and when and we write this
how many messages to another topic et
cetera so then we can have an aggregate
review so have our same workflow running
either hourly or daily to comparator and
to any numbers to see their differences
yeah so logging only really matters when
somebody does something about the fact
that there's a problem so are you
planning on building or do you have some
sort of like this thing is a failure and
it should be assigned to this person and
like tracking on whether or not they're
going to we're building something
somewhere right now and I'm like
struggling with how do you define which
errors go to which teens and then
afterwards how do you know whether
they've resolved it so the question was
are you talking about logging innocent
in the context of application logs where
the server logs errors or is it in the
context of general locking sure that's a
great question so so this like the so
basically if you find any data quality
issue it can range from like the how the
the the metric were how the metric was
computed to the way of the data was loud
correctly or was there any sort of
problem in the pipeline right so
generally the investigation so someone
could actually point out a bucket could
be a sort of on the product side or a
business analyst and it comes down to us
to actually carry out the investigation
but as we go into places there for
example if we do find that this was
actually a problem in the mobile and a
particular mobile release where so we
forgot to log the a portion correctly so
we were not measuring the TA use so then
we basically follow up with a mobile
team and then ask their responsibility
to actually fix it but the investigation
is actually carried out by our team the
data
for the recording thanks you guys
introduced a single for you no data
failure because of Kafka and I saw in
your architecture you have a spam
detection afterwards do you guys do
filtering in single if it is the case
why spam detection is done later at the
stage not in the previous the my second
question is have you guys evaluated
Kinesis vs. Kafka because that will
solve your both problems I believe based
on my understanding I want to ask that
question forgot sorry yeah so the first
question was like why do we do spam
detection in a different service than
actually singer right so the way we look
at it I mean we I mean if you look at if
we looked at the evolution of the
architecture you see that there are a
lot of decoupling going on so that's
cool
that's been our mantra to the to to to
things with separation of concerns have
individual teams work on what they need
to work on and I separate out the
abstractions in a clean way and also to
reduce the failures of one system
avoiding the other right number two is
so the spam detection system has a lot
of things going on to it so we basically
have we have these non-engineers
like the operations people the community
operations such people that react to
spam on the side and they come up with
like hey this new kind of spam is coming
in the end code in your rule and so that
rule has to be processed on any queue so
essentially the system is built in a way
that it can read from Kafka or later on
it can read from anything else right so
it doesn't really need to happen on the
web servers if you think about singer is
actually like a logging agent that's
actually collecting so one way you can
actually transport the rules to be
detected at that place it's just much
more convenient to actually do it at the
level where you're reading from Kafka
because a you can actually do the same
apply the same rule on historical data
because oftentimes we may detect a new
spam rule and say like how the same
system that applies date rules on the
real time should also apply it on the
historic
so that just makes it very convenient
and the second question was why not
Kinesis and why Kafka so I think if I
remember correctly when we started
introducing Kafka I don't think aneesa's
existed in Amazon and we saw bees we
were already on Kafka but that doesn't
prevent us like from looking at Amazon
our philosophy at Pinterest has been to
be as cloud agnostic as possible and as
we try to scale our business we use
Amazon mostly for ec2 and s3 right and
and except for redshift which is the
only other Amazon service that we use we
don't use anything else I mean that
actually is philosophically allows us to
like build either build in-house or use
open source right versus own using an
Amazon service because that allows us to
move to a different route in the future
singer itself is the process and as yeah
another reason that I think it is we
don't use cases is efficiency reasons so
comparing to using connexxus and it's
more efficient so we just deployed the
caja message systems and operate
everything by ourselves yeah one more
yeah I have a question regarding the
format so looks to me using more C or C
code to reading from Kafka and writing
to as three so what kind of woman are
you choosing also second question are
you guys considering upgrading to cap
cap point nine yeah so the question is
first opposed which is the format we
processed at 3 the second is are we
considering upgrading cough at the point
9 the the first question is right there
are multiple formats we can support one
in the sequence file and we are also
considering parquet right now and with
the sequence file format when we user we
are evaluating various compression
algorithms
currently we are using the gzip
compression to minimize this storage
footprint yeah
and for the upgrading path right we are
considering upgrading to point nine
which was came out late last year and
maybe in q2
I think the because we are also
evaluating kafka streams to do the
streamline processing thing yeah thank
you guys